obviously this is a controversy when you
talk about dolphins a being I mean
there's a difference between people
paying hundreds of thousands of dollars
of dot for dolphins to sell tickets to
their aquarium but what about when
there's dolphins that were injured like
for example in Clearwater there's this
dolphin named winter who had it state
who his tail was caught in a net they
had to surgically remove its tail and
build it up builded a prosthetic tail
and you know their claim to fame at
Clearwater Marine Aquarium is that
they'll sort of rescue dolphins who have
been seriously injured that can't
survive in the wild by themselves and
they'll take care of him there right so
that dolphin I mean it was a dolphin was
probably gonna die and now they rescued
her and she's living now in a sewage
treatment plant that 600,000 people a
year have to want to see her and
clapping and screaming at her like she
what did she get saved from exactly I'm
not sure like yeah surely that place was
a sewage treatment plant that's a motor
marine aquarium at the old sewage
treatment plant for clear water
how many dolphins have they released
since since that movie came out how many
none right that is just it's pure
exploitation it's like just because you
make a sign that says rescue rehab and
release or a sanctuary doesn't mean
that's what it is
like they literally I think in 2015 when
that movie came out they had 800,000
visitors there every one of them wants
to see winner winner is in an old round
sewage treatment tank there is nothing
when you go to a zoo even the snake gets
more consideration than the dolphin when
you look at the snake in his tank
there's a rock and a stick and if the
snake wants to get away from people he
can go behind this the rock the dolphin
isn't gonna completely bear it there is
nothing in that tank she can't get away
the the winners just stalk all day every
kid is screaming at the top of their
lungs in a line and then you walk past
Windsor right into a gift shop that's
what it's all about it's just about
exploitation and money right they wanted
to do something with women
Feuer the ocean is literally 50 yards
away
why do you build a sea pen right there
why is she in the sewage treatment tank
in a building that's not rescuing they
kept her alive but that's not living is
doing things if you're not doing things
you're not living that's August that
often is just existing it's a very sad
situation it's pure exploitation yes
David Gates like when that movie came
out his bio on his Twitter was winters
agent I saw that what is that like so
cringe that guy I mean I helped work on
that movie and I had no idea about any
of this and it's just how can we exploit
this situation you know and it's like
now they're talking about building this
massive new facility
well that NASA facility is gonna need
more dolphins that they generate income
to get people in there it's just a
revolving door of like this and it is
massive man I drove by the other day it
is they are expanding it it's now it's
gone to like four stories I believe and
we have the only dolphin sanctuary in
the world I built it for about $75,000
in about three weeks done yeah
the open ocean it also can dolphins can
see the stars at night they're in the
open ocean the tide comes in out every
day so there's a current to move against
there's little sounds of the snapping
shrimp
there's fish and swimming in and out of
the pen that's living at least that's
some sort of something right there just
existing and for what purpose like there
is I have yet to hear any justifiable
reason for having a dolphin in captivity
like they're not ambassadors a dolphin
is no more an ambassador than for
dolphins than like Mickey Mouse's for
mice like these are just character
jurors of the animals and the whether or
not they don't represent the animals in
the wild they're not doing any behaviors
that the animals in the wild do like
this is just a force together group of
dolphins that we've made and like you
know because oh well if the children
don't see them then how are they going
to learn about them we're educating a
hundred million you know a hundred
million people come through SeaWorld
every year that we're educating
that is ridiculous like I know
eight-year-olds the average
eight-year-old boy knows like half of
the scientific names for dinosaurs and
the crustacean period that they lived in
we've never seen a dinosaur I've never
seen the dinosaur yeah kids know a name
of every freaking - or and what what
period they lived in elephants we've had
since the beginning of time have been in
captivity um they're on the verge of
extinction I've never I worked with
dolphins
I've never real-life seen a blue whale
yet the blue whales came off the
endangered species list without anyone
seeing it so there's no correlation
seeing an animal and saving it like that
if that were true I think they say in
Japan like yeah I forgot the number a
hundred million people a year and go
through their aquariums well all those
people are going through the
dolphinariums that are educated when the
dolphins are being slaughtered where are
all these people I'm but I'm there by
myself like where are they you're not
getting any educate you're not leaving -
eek whirring and being told that these
dolphins are dying like this is what you
can do you don't don't eat tuna like
dolphins are dying tuna nets are being
slaughtered for this you don't get any
of that
like there's no education happening
there no was that and yeah dolphins if
you think about all animals in captivity
like the most modern zoo now they try to
make it like the elephants or on an
island there's like a moat and there it
looks like wherever and they're just
being elephants the Dolphins are
literally evolutionary the highest
animal and yet they're the only ones
left that have to perform six times a
day seven days a week there's a show
begging for their food like doing the
stupid apps the dumbest tricks wearing a
Christmas hat or a fake beard or putting
out a fire it's like that's like the 50s
some clown thing from the 50s like yeah
no it literally is that's the dolphin
version of tiger King it's just absurd
like that really painted a very clear
picture of it I mean especially rang
true with me with just thinking of that
guy Chris Porter and David Yates he's
kind of like the Chris Porter of clear
water in a way
[Laughter]